Що зберігається в цих мармурових скринях?
Італійський делікатес, який роблять лише в єдиному селі у світі.
Маріно Джаннареллі - один з дванадцяти фахівців, який вміє готувати цей делікатес.
І зараз він розкриє нам свій секрет.
Цей саркофаг уже готовий. А цей ми почали минулого тижня. Частина солі вже розчинилася.
Село Колонната розташоване в горах Каррари - зі своїми легендарними, тисячолітніми мармуровими кар'єрами.
Понад 70 років родина Джаннареллі у спеціальних мармурових ваннах готує найвідоміше у світі італійське сало - Лардо ді Колонната.
Колись воно було єдиним повноцінним прийомом їжі для працівників місцевого кар'єру.
Сало беремо з італійських свиней. Відрізаємо всі шматочки м'яса, щоб сіль краще вбиралася.
Тонкі скибочки лардо можна використовувати замість олії, для ароматизації супів або прикраси м'ясних страв.
Але спочатку лардо довго визріває.
Свіжі шматки сала заготовляють з жовтня до квітня - у цей час не так спекотно.
Сало вивалюють у морській солі, а потім - без додавання консервантів - щільно упаковують у мармурові ємності.
Додають спеції: обов'язково розмарин та часник, а також деякі інші - на смак майстра.
Це суміш гвоздики, мускатного горіха, зірчастого анісу та чорного перцю.
Тепер закриваємо кришку - для дозрівання лардо потрібно шість місяців.
Це Фаусто Гваданьї.
Він відіграв ключову роль у створенні торгової марки Lardo di Colonnata.
Нині у селі виробляють понад 200 тонн сала щороку.
У Колоннаті - лише близько 300 мешканців.
Майже у кожному будинку є власний льох, висічений у скелі, з мармуровими скринями для визрівання вишуканого лардо.
Усі ці ванни зроблені з каррарського мармуру "каналоні" - з околиць Колоннати.
Мармур доволі непроникний, але все ж таки він дихає.
Цим скриням близько 200 років, ми миємо їх тільки водою та оцтом.
Лардо ді Колонната винайшли радше випадково.
Робочі історично відомих кар'єрів Каррари опівдні їли товсті скибки лардо.
Вони й виявили, що сало довше залишалося свіжим у мармурових печерах.
Лардо був основним продуктом харчування для працівників кар'єру.
Вони могли зберігати його понад рік. Люди також дарували лардо друзям, родичам, лікарям...
Нині важку роботу в кар'єрах виконують машини.
Але лардо, як і раніше, популярне як самостійний делікатес, так і для приготування інших страв.
Що відрізняє Лардо ді Колонната - то це те, наскільки воно ніжне.
Сало відкривається у той момент, коли потрапляє до вас на тарілку.
У роті не має бути ані шматочка жиру.
Воно справді має танути в роті.
І в міру того, як ви жуєте, ви поступово відкриваєте для себе спеції та аромати.
Лардо буквально тане у роті...
Лардо - це наша історія. Завдяки лардо ця місцевість і люди особливі.
Вартість Лардо ді Колонната - від 30 до 50 євро за кілограм.
Завдяки йому це село в Тоскані прославилося на весь світ.